my name is Steve burn
I am a stand-up comedian on a weekday
I'll do anywhere from like four to five
shows a night and then a weekend it
could be anywhere from like 4:00 to 8:00
or 9:00
if you hustle you can do eight clubs the
most I've ever done was eight you know I
can't do that I guess an average number
on a weekend would be six five two six
four million budget somebody had Tim
scheduling only made nine uh control the
most I ever heard was 11 to do tall
would be great to do 39 you're really
cool 13 shows in one night this is the
only city you can do it you can never do
13 shows as comedian anywhere else
like the most ever did I think was 11 in
one night and I was just like you know
what I just want to find out what the
most is and push myself to the limit I
guess hey Bobby Steve no I listen I just
want to ask you like what what is the
most number of sets you know somebody
didn't in the city and in one night 12
we have to do more than 12 that means we
have to do 13 or bust
Dalila and Steve are in Hawaii good good
yeah I was just calling to confirm my
950 I was just calling to confirm his
spots at hot Saturday for the 720 and
740 by 12:40 my 1155 for 650 and then
the second one at 10:35 120 I've made 45
in the 915 my 1110 right to 10:30 no one
night I believe it can be done I think
it can be done we have this schedule
that says it can be done it's possible
it's just nothing can go wrong there's a
hundred different variables that go into
something like this because it's not
just about me it's about 11 different
clubs six other comedians on each show
and you pray to God that all those
things all work in your favor and
everything wants a court
plan so as long as I stick to my plan
all those other comics and all those in
the comedy club stick to their plan then
this should work out and we can beat the
record New York right now this is the
first first show we're going up to the
comic strip so on the upper east side of
the city this is a club that's known for
a lot of guys starting off out there
like Seinfeld Eddie Murphy it's like
well it's a club with a lot of history
what can we expect tonight a lot of
running around a lot of drunk people
it's the holidays a lot of fun it'll be
cool but it's gonna go by quick but here
it is here's our first show here we go
this is my headshot over here I'll show
you
when I was like like I said comic when
you're first starting off you want to
pass here you want to pass at the
college you know when you first start
wondering goes to the city you're doing
crappy gigs then you move to the clubs
on weekends then you move to outside
clubs like you know feature in Midland
and then you move to college and you
start doing colleges then you move to
headlining clubs where you start hitting
on a club you're not making money like
none of us are famous like you know
whoever the Chris Rock or whatever but
we'll make good money and we'll get
taken care of just no way to make this
business Silvia guys been doing it way
long and then you finally get something
oh there be a guy who's been doing for a
couple weeks and you're thinking he's
back hanoks nice end at home you see him
you know we got a bottom like a sitcom
it's just like no we can't yeah you
can't ever you can't have a look at that
you know you just gotta do your thing
and and in some ways I mean terms of the
odds and probability you're lucky to
make it there most common most people
don't make it do me doing anything and
then those guys literally 300 guys I
mean you know every [ __ ] weirdo plate
spinner whack-job delusional animal from
you know the four corners is their
audition but did they show them year
after year and they usually put you up
after somebody who's gonna kill that's
the Boston yes that's the cellar the
sell sell it she'll put you up and they
both they'll watch you and then want you
know this sit there and then you'll do
five minutes and if you do good you
might you get the thumbs up will get
Everlast most people never most people
never get an audition yeah you never get
an audition yeah I gave her my tape cuz
you got to give her a tape I hear on my
tape and it took eight months for it
even yeah you look at a mission called
me you do these shows at night so that
you can go on Jimmy Kimmel or you can go
on Conan or Letterman or
Leno and do well you know this is what
all that is for tonight at all any
agents I repeat any agents of course not
they're all stuffy god bless us
yesterday how I'm gonna react do I make
noise when I move well let me explain if
you see I'm Asian you or not that's hell
I feel bad for Asian actors that's why I
feel bad for Asian actors can't even get
cast in movies about Asians you know do
you remember the Karate Kid sorry ruff
much milk do they say wealth mega the
less samurai starring Tom Cruise what
the [ __ ] is going on
it's like what's next Vicky a change
story over think about the life of Jim
Katina an angel all right these next two
will be similar to that these club is a
little more kind of condensed there's
usually tourists from all over the world
you know because this is right by Time
Square
how are you there's another Club right
upstairs well not a room so we'll just
do this one and then literally by the
time I finish this one he'll be right
upstairs to brighten up and then we do
that one or whatever Caroline's house
one time I don't like being with my mama
to church no she thinks she's a good
singer
we're going to do the same exact set of
some crowds on that hot on what's going
on and then some love it
puppies funny always have anything else
ticket much trying to create this party
atmosphere like you walk in my can't
even stick but a slit the wall were
crazy horrible now we're running off to
Caroline's ten minutes hey how you doing
a Steve Byrne how's it going I got cut
off from your a second ago but I'm just
letting you know I'm right around the
corner I'm doing like a five minute
guess spot at eight o'clock yeah just
let me know I'll be there and like a did
I'll just I was just letting you know
I'll be there but definitely my eight
o'clock okay okay thank you I like where
it's just like on the go you just got it
one over there there's a Time Square
moment here
I think comics get chicks if they want
to if they pursue it you know but I mean
you're essentially up on stage for 20
minutes in front of you know on a
weekend 300 200 people give the life of
the party you made everybody laugh and
there's gonna be girls that are
attracted to that you know and then they
come up to you afterwards and or some
guys sit in a bar by the exit door
waiting to be like hey oh thanks you
know but I don't know it's like I know
on the back of my mind that if I went
into a bar and approached that give me
the time of day so I keep that you know
these girls you know what oh my god this
is my boyfriend you bang a lot no but
even like musicians if you like it an
open mic i mean those flowers like the
stereotype goes it's like you know you
know you strum a couple of chords and
you're gonna have a couple of groupies
comedians even when you kill you still
have to work it afterwards but what
sucks is they saw you kill and then they
think you're gonna be that funny the
whole [ __ ] time which is impossible
and totally unnatural to sustain and if
you actually try to do it you just come
off as irritating so yeah it's a weird
thing where it's you not starting off
the ground yeah you know you know no
one's complaining on it it's this
variable well you yet you get back what
you put he's just saying that most girls
think that you're gonna be that guy all
the time yeah like you're gonna come off
stage you glad so you wanna get
so was good yo good show
oh that show was fun yeah that's a nice
one yeah maybe we can get laid out of
this huh how's it going
Caroline uh it's a great club it's a
headlining club it would be sold out of
probably 300 some people this will be a
really nice one this is one where as
opposed to the last three I won't really
joke around as much I'll just kind of
bang it out but it's only five minutes
as well so there's nothing worse than
like doing your act in front of a
sold-out satyr Saturday night show with
Caroline's and as soon as you get up
some jackass wants to be a part of your
strategy
I just didn't handle it alone oh I was
handling it like there was like 15
people in a club it's a sold-out show
and Here I am wasting my time talking
some you know you guys and nobody knows
what the hell is going on and in 5 min
if I had 15 minutes that's different but
I got 5 minutes
so by the time I started digging myself
out of the hole it's too late so it'll
be an afterthought by the evening here
we go
I'm actually right on the dot I'll show
you this one's starting now so I'm gonna
go I don't know if we have time to go
here here boom now there's two types of
teams people get to work on themselves
you got your workout tapes like John
bass down and you got your porno tapes
right now what does it say about us a
wallet did indicate place time to a
workouts but more time to a porno for
example 500 abs easy easy please
10-minute buns of steel don't push it
please but you're gonna do it two and a
half hours of facial humiliation
thank you it done Warren's become a more
mainstream I think they just need to
soften it up a bit you know thrown some
nice touches I came up with an idea you
know we showed a couple going every
which way the oral the oral blah blah
then you show the guy then you show that
same couple at the end together holding
a baby hey nice job you really know how
to take the pounding angel we're gonna
go in this one oops
you know witness the magic do you think
no this is hot hot yeah what a lot of
energy in this room and honestly like it
doesn't get worse than that what could
be worse than that
don't do this gig which it's a college
gig outside in the rain underneath an
awning there forty feet away from me
underneath an awning at a beer fest
after a band with a skydiving simulator
next to me and not to mention the guy
that goes by with the funnel every forty
minutes and I pull it off all right
people we gotta rent this up here I
gotta listen once you get momentum going
you can't stomp it don't talk about I'm
a conductor of comedy people all aboard
next stop last film it's like there's
some guys that would go into a situation
like that and let the environment really
get to them again [ __ ] just sucks
there's times where I still do this and
I I mean I do it every night now I see
somebody smiling and I know that they're
paying money to be there you got to do
your best form you know it's tough
though the situation like that it's just
that's a horrible room to do comedy but
it's like that's just one other room in
the city if you don't there's gonna be
this you know college gig with a
thousand people turn out there were
thirty acidic students in a room and
they didn't use a microphone because it
was on the Sabbath day so there was no
technology allowed so I had to stand on
top of a radiator and her Ranga budget
has seeds for 40 minutes and there was a
I'd the harangue these because because
you have to yell yo through the
dictionary every day try to take out
interests know I'm relatively illiterate
because I've read I need to be fun
completed grade school he said a
radiator how's your schedule next week
are you open you taking more on it's our
job to make other people laugh and you
know we sit around waiting to go on
making each other laugh as well so it's
it's just nice hanging out with these
guys it's a lot of fun I haven't had
this this type of friendship since high
school hanging out and shooting the [ __ ]
and doing comedy shows and eating food
it's cuz I'm tired make everything every
night yeah yeah so it is like please
dude you're filming a bunch four humps
okay why cuz we do come
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Steve Byrnes rockin it out good to be
here
I feel like I'm on a cruise ship hmm
Seifer ladies and gentlemen that was uh
that was interesting I wouldn't even
know how else to describe that one other
than what the [ __ ] was that
look down here how you doing sir go into
a 82nd and second this is like gonna be
the fun part of the night I think these
next two if these Lakes shows a pack
that the later shows a pack then it's
gonna be a lot of fun you know we kind
of got the ones that are a little more
baking out of the way in the earlier
ones so just a bit cool now the glimmer
is backstage I'm actually a Korean an
Irish Caucasian and Asian which makes me
Caucasian
it makes you feel good you feel good you
walk out and you go dude
I finally I did my act the way I wanted
to be done and they got it and they
[ __ ] got it every 30 seconds they
[ __ ] laughed wherever the [ __ ] I
wanted to and it built and I said thank
you and they went wha
and they applauded cuz they don't know
what else to have to do I don't care who
you are that makes you feel like man
that's a [ __ ] drug and you'll stay up
all night all night with that [ __ ] all
night and you just have the audience in
the palm of your hand you can you you
it's a there's some nights you could
virtually say anything and it's just
like for some reason they're just with
you
Bruce Lee movies come from when there's
enough of that for gossip but Bruce Lee
I always feel bad for Linda Lee Bruce
Lee's wife cause she had sex with this
guy night after night after night so
here's my take on sex in the bracele
household excuse me your honey and you
would like to make love to me all
evening long not a damn thing apart
I am family trained
I don't mean a puncher mom so sorry I
I'm gonna feel good
oh don't don't hum tender okay
it's addictive in the sense that look it
I'll work every night
I'll be on the road I'll be up all night
I'll be flying in and out I'll come back
and I'll still put on a veil so Friday
and Saturday night and I'll take sunday
off and I'll feel [ __ ] up when I'm
home because I don't want to be home I
want to be down the club because I feel
like somebody's getting on if somebody's
doing something I could be on and you
get that instant gratification every 30
seconds pom pom pom and when you're done
you get you a freaking great by a couple
of people and then you go home and you
feel fart it's a drug you know I mean
it's a drug you want to feel like that
is so nice you're like wow that was fun
it's almost like I should pay the club
for letting me do that you know not the
other way around
I was seeing this girl and I came home I
did a spot at the strip and like during
the week they literally pay you like
eight bucks
eight dollars it's like [ __ ] himself
and it's five dollars up to ten thirty
something like that so I get like eight
bucks I come home and I did some new bit
and then it worked and I was psyched I
was like bouncing off the walls and she
kind of got like depressed for a second
looking at me I was like what's the
matter she goes I want a job like your
job where even if I get paid eight bucks
I'm still like like excited as hell now
we are going to Dangerfield's to the
oldest club and then happen and here we
are
but eight minutes to spare I was like
again everyone likes together guys to
trouble us as the most girls can dance
most guys get nuts guys if you're on the
dance floor if you're not getting or
blanket drink as much liquor and she
looks stupid but you won't steal it cuz
the girls not gonna turn around hey you
wanna dance
no she's gonna move then you're gonna
keep up they give me a gun your subway
situation you can't handle
the guys are back trying to keep all the
keys and rodeos
how's fun get some time
how awesome wouldn't be that was for us
you know
and I gotta get a [ __ ] camera
Oh
it's like midnight we've done a nine
shows and we've got four left we just
finished the danger pills we're heading
over to stand up New York you guys suck
ass P that is awful joke that's why
these guys have their Alps in this
business thing yeah hit the net right
exactly
I feel sorry for them I tried to mix it
up as much as I can but well you get a
whole nother hour to go to hide this is
a it's the same [ __ ] material I told
him I probably have idyllic Bruce Lee
once this whole evening I you did yeah
how many times I've done that Bruce Lee
the comic strip is it big as a heavy
fear of intimacy
as you most 5-second you look for big
wonderful between intimacy a function
that has a direct one it's distinct and
the reasons I use the word f28 yeah he
was about to say a word that he had
known they had to use so we come to
south wall I've learned one thing one
thing I did do a commie this long I have
no friends don't even buy that you know
what that that's not the dude who always
threatens to commit suicide just want to
hear how much we like a [ __ ] book
yeah Bobby has lots of friends very
popular he grew up in a way that I would
imagine horribly dysfunctional and he
scarred for life
this is you know his reactions
everything his observations are informed
by his vicious dysfunction why does
everything sound like a self-help book
coming out of your mouth not self-help
Amelia am i lyin I think you're a good
guy and I like you and now you're a
little out of your mind and those are
the reasons why not you saying I'm any
I'm just saying that isn't everything
about trying to find a way to exist
until it exists in an optimal way and
then that feels relatively fulfilling
until you drop dead I mean isn't that
what life this world Wow okay can you
make that a [ __ ] two-shot like I'm
not can you send it to me and put it in
a front up I never knew what a pessimist
yeah I'm gonna buy you off farm I read a
lot philosophy and apparently you want
us to know that my TV back on don't want
you to know that dummy I don't usually
work with those you know so I didn't
realize what a [ __ ] he's really
trying to come on really puts a big
words you know what he's gonna be he's
trying to be the guy who didn't get into
this business to be famous and to fill
up that [ __ ] void inside of you up on
a freakin India on a friggin combinator
Communist China being experiences wears
his shirts inside out because I know he
is
he's a thin headed friggin dummy is it
does dick jokes and he throws big words
in it to make it sound like he's
smarting to tell you know that many
talks with like bongos in the background
exactly when people when people they
don't applaud them they do this don't
ask him no more questions I'll be like
Smee you can't call another co-worker
Merrill Lynch a [ __ ] org or
a big ape or and you know you can't just
be demeaning like this this environment
guys are just downright mean to each
other but it's hilarious
have you seen these girls how about Anne
Frank everybody huh you got a do it
I was watching extreme television
everybody [ __ ] Fox because I saw this
dude on fire so I'm laughing because I
honestly what is the first thing you
learn to do if you ever catch fire stop
drown what is idiots always doing good
where you going I'm gonna outrun fire I
just called Gotham just let him know it
won't be there
I'll be right on time hey how's it going
Steve Byrne how you doing so you guys
know that Ben and I switch right then
Ben Bailey he's got the 12 5501 the 110
you see all right easy there now this is
it
this is gonna better usually these late
shows at Gotham I'll tell you I either
do really well or I like badly I don't
see you or talk to you make love to you
online I can't help myself that's ready
to I gotta take this party train on
downtown I don't know another haha hard
to hit something really really bad in a
few places wonder how'd that feel so you
guys crazy stick with it
shut up bill if I bomb I'll give a [ __ ]
I mean I've you once you've done it long
enough it's it's in the beginning that
it kills because you don't know am I
good at this
yeah am I gonna be able to do this so
when you bomb it's really like [ __ ] man
maybe maybe on that guy maybe I'm that
guy that guy who sucks you know like I
didn't get one time and literally I mean
no laughs I was hosting a show nothing
went up did five minutes brought that
they got nothing brought the middle like
he kind of did okay I went up again
five more minutes nothing it was so bad
I literally ran out the back of the club
cuz I didn't want to hear what people
had to say and this couple was walking
by it I knew I shouldn't have listened
but I had to it was kind of an okay show
and the girls like is it usually like
that
the guys like no it's usually funny man
you know he's
yeah that reddit guys sucked else it's
like ah had to go back to my day job it
was like eight days that's my next show
next show and I had to carry that in my
head oh that was horrible
as long as majority of time I say like
80 90 to 95 percent of time you're doing
really well then you should be doing
this but you know I mean you're gonna
have no place it happens hey it's Steve
Byrne I'm just telling you that I'm
right around the corner okay yeah I'm
gonna be there less than that [ __ ]
idiot that [ __ ] idiot
totally took us the wrong [ __ ] way
yeah I love macaroni cheese my favorite
part of me at least even eating it how
weird is that is preparing it do this
with next time your bowl take a spill d
video your pasta mister mister trick
don't eat it just unless you appreciate
your mail that much more you take a
spoon just
I gotta stop cuz it gettin hungry here
all right there
I think everybody likes the mac and
cheese I'll tell you who lumps it my
next-door neighbor yeah shoot a bowl
last night at 1:00 in the morning for an
hour and 17 goddamn minutes I know cuz I
had my ear up against the wall and all
night long all I hear next door is like
hey don't eat so fast you're gonna choke
you know my favorite part about that
joke is so many ladies over the next
night or two next time you hear for one
brief shining moment guess who's smiling
face get up here in your little heads
god bless you is that good to see
watching a friend said it's funny but
it's like especially on the weekends
like like he's not gonna try out new
stuff you know just going to do those
adult stuff so
now we all know each other's actually
well you could I can play putting on the
hits with it like Baba's say nice things
like you blow or you suck [ __ ]
now dummy seriously we know we don't you
know what is some people do that some
comics would do that but guys like us
will watch each other and you know what
will [ __ ] with each other somebody's
doing something you know that's kind of
stupid will be like third you [ __ ] him
if you get him [ __ ] with them but you
haven't stopped doing it in a cool way
and then when they do something good
it's like dude that's a good joke and
yeah but it's almost like you know you
don't want to come up all the time
dude that's great I'm working on this
I'm working cuz then it's like annoying
and fake but if I he comes up to me and
says dude that jokes cool I know it
means it's kind of got cool I know
that's composite there's like an
etiquette where if your friends met a
person if you're tight with them then
you can come up and say something too
but there's nothing more irritating is
if you do that to somebody something you
don't even know and it's up to you and
start to critique in your act especially
if they suck - it's just like that once
you go work on your own yeah [ __ ]
horror so the last one last one
gentleman
if you're in this business about trying
to get money or people this again that's
all you're wrong nothing wrong with that
it's nothing wrong with a lot of things
but if that's the objective right you're
gonna be in you just be a miserable gut
when Bobby gets his TV show and become
thing he's gonna realize that it's
hollow just like every other things
person it's not if you can still have
fun with it no you're absolutely right
now Billy you know what you're
absolutely right but I'll have him sign
one out and it joins your fame not
everybody but it's not saying it's not
about good it's not it's not bad money's
not bad to be rich isn't bad but that
fame isn't bad but you know what use
you're absolutely right you have to
enjoy what you're right yeah absolutely
I do
absolutely I'm not trying to become
famous I'm trying to get on stage and do
my comedy more poundings you get the
more rejection you get the more tough
skin you get the more the closer you get
to who you are you have no choice to
what you'll accept and what you won't
accept it and then that gets you closer
to your comedy because they just stopped
being more honest in everyday life with
people you interact with and then when
something goes down okay when you
finally get your opportunity
you're not gonna accept crap you look
except you know something they give you
that it goes against your character and
what you are you're gonna go now I want
to do that because you're happy with
what you're doing anyways that's one
thing we all have we're happy now so
what if you give us is bonus make it
mobile [ __ ] loud
this is ladies here it was like this
whole weather like it when it's kind of
cold out goes like it is akin to light
enter this in there let's keep each
other type of blanket that'll keep him
warm you just think like the Heisman
Trophy like this love it
does it get to lay down might do this so
tired my mouth all day in the room right
now just talking myself hey what's going
on something just right stop rubbing
that watching this I just said I'm
relaxing my god yeah Hannibal you just
can you do that can just spin you want
me to go get you spoon now why don't you
two get me a spoon I want you to become
a spoon to do that can become a spill
become let's see who I'm laying in the
food you become this will be overlapping
spin puzzle pieces really fit oh you
want me to lay like a [ __ ]
that's it on my arm if you guess tickle
my arm there you go don't tickle me just
tickle me
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
become a tickling spoon just tickle me
just take your fingertips and will then
slowly just touch me don't touch me
touch me I'm good in the bathroom you
just touch me
13 one night pretty cool everything
works out you know Cavs time what by
quick I think we broke the record would
you do 13 what is this stupid we're
filming heroes one more get hungry you
ever drink have you ever seen a
documentary before this is a one-man
show you [ __ ] you see you soon are
trying to answer a question in a
substantial way Miss illiterate jumps in
illiterate sit down watch an area that
is New York sweatshirt it has a walking
billboard you can't listen to people and
labels all over the clothes I can't
nobody here is a label dumb it down
stupid alright stop using your elicit
and all these big [ __ ] words know
what you're saying by the way that was
an oxymoronic statement because you told
me to dumb it down at the same time you
called me stupid what rights is this
gentlemen is it out of order he's out of
order are you done good at 9:15